alors dites moi mon cher prisonniers
sudiste
c'est commencer j'ai l'impression que
pour vous la guerre de sécession à ccc
si on avait dû répondre ça c'est sûr
mais dites moi maintenant que vous êtes
sont entre nos mains
vous n'avez rien à déclarer on ti a chez
nous entre les sudistes
on avait été plus nombreux il est bien
vous autres les nordistes vous auriez
bel et bien pris la pente
est-ce que vous répétez riez ce que vous
venez de dire je m'en prends pourquoi
que j'aurais peut-être répond si les
sudistes
il avait été plus nombreux et bien les
nordistes mon dieu il a révélé bien
après la pratique mais avez vous
l'impression que vous dites ça nordiste
qu'elle leur dise n'importe quelle
lourde ou à nous abonde par vous vous
êtes caporal non alors vous êtes serge
et un sergent nordiste vous auriez le
culot de répéter votre petit leitmotiv
la même énergie diméthyle sudiste il a
été plus nombreux et la pâtée
et je ne suis pas certain et bien ça
arrange tout ça cela génère altran ça
n'arrange rien du tout et en général
croit que vous seriez répété au bayern
aa je ferai pas des bêtises de bol
général
ça serait que culottée bien ça ce serait
d'abord jean marc ferry et dans la
conversation je ne dis pas le glissement
que c'est une des mes diplômes la
battait oui mais surtout notre minute
pour changer de compte de silence hymne
aux gens vous fussiez à sa sauce oui
mais vous faire écouter ça réfléchit à a
dégagé avec pour effet si c'est vital
dufour pas cher nordiste permettait aux
usa par exemple montrant famille avec ça
yes yes yes you little sauvage et où
chatouille toi maintenant que vous êtes
de l'autre un content on l'a échappé
belle
comment ça on l'a échappé belle si ces
salopards de sudistes il avait été plus
nombreux nous autres les nordistes on
prend le bel et bien la patte et vous
savez